الينا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط
هشام ما الذي سجل في الساعات الاخيره
وماذا عن حده القصف والغارات
الاسرائيليه ما يسجل دائما وابدا هو
استمرار للقصف الاسرائيلي لا سما المدفعي
ربما في ساعات النهار تنخفض حده الغارات
الاسرائيليه لكن حتى اليوم هي لم تنخفض
وتركزت في مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع وهذه
المناط جباليا وبيت لاهيا وبيت حنون
ومدينه غزه باحيائها جميعها بدت تتعرض ما
بين الفينه والاخرى الى قصف عنيف من
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه وجل هذه
الاستهدافات هي منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه
وعندما نتحدث عن مدينه غزه نحن نتحدث عن
المدينه التي دمرت غالبيه احيائها
وبالتالي المنازل التي ظلت قائمه في هذه
المدينه وفي شمال القطاع هي مكتظه عن بكره
ابيها واي قصف اسرائيلي بكل تاكيد هناك
شهداء وجرحى بالعشرات من جراء هذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه ايضا الغارات كانت مكثفه على
وسط القطاع مخيم المغازي مخيم البريج
وكذلك مخيم النصيرات الذي شهد غاره قبل
قليل واستهدفت مجموعه من المواطنين في
شارع العشرين ونقل عدد من الشهداء والجرحى
على الاقل شهيدين من جراء هذه الغاره وعدد
من الاصابات نقلوا الى مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في وسط القطاع في دير البلح ايضا
الغارات كانت مستمره ومتواصله على مخيم
المغازي لا سما الاطراف الش قيه من هذا
المخيم التي تتعرض في كل لحظه وفي كل حين
الى قصف من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه القصف
بات مركزا من المدفعيه على هذه المناطق
وهذه المناطق هي مناطق ماهوله ما بين
زراعيه وما بين منازل المدنيين
الفلسطينيين وجل المنازل المدنيه في مخيم
المغازي على وجه الخصوص دمرت او طالها
الضرر من جراء الغارات الكثيفه على هذا
المخيم الصغير والمكر والذي يحتوي على
منازل بسيطه اغلب هذه المنازل في مخيم
المغازي هي من الصفيح ومن من الاسبست
وبالتالي الغارات الاسرائيليه تدمر هذه
المنازل ودمرت على مدار الايام الماضيه
العديد من الاحياء والعديد من المربعات
السكنيه نسفت من جراء حده الغارات
الاسرائيليه في تلك المناطق مخيم النصيرات
ايضا يتعرض الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه لا
سما المناطق الشماليه للمخيم التي باتت
تتعرض الى القصف ربما الاكثر عنفا والاكثر
حده كذلك هناك غارات ما بين الفينه
والاخرى واحزمه ناريه تنفذ على المربعات
السكنيه والاحياء في هذا المخيم ايضا مخيم
النصيرات هو مخيم مكتظ لكن في ظل استمرار
القصف الاسرائيلي فهناك اعداد كبيره من
النازحين الذين يلجؤون الى دير البلح ورفح
التي تعرضت هي الاخرى مدينه رفح الى غاره
قبل نحو ساعه من الانعم واستهدفت ايضا
منزلا يتواجد فيه نازحون فلسطينيون في
المناطق الغربيه لرفح والمناطق الغربيه
لرفح هي المناطق الانسانيه التي يتحدث
الجيش الاسرائيلي انها مناطق انسانيه ويضع
خريطه ويقول انها مناطق انسانيه ويعود
ليقص هذه المناطق التي يلجا اليها
النازحون هي كانت مناطق سياحيه لا يتواجد
فيها سكان بكثره ولا يوجد فيها كثافه
سكانيه الان باتت هذه المناطق هي الاكثر
كثافه سكانيه ربما في مدينه رفح وفي مدينه
خانيونس كذلك وكل هذه المناطق يتواجد فيها
نازحون نصبوا خياما او لجوا الى المنازل
التي عددها قليل في تلك المنطقه والتي لا
يتوفر فيها ادنى مقومات الحياه لا يوجد
فيها بنى تحتيه ولا يوجد فيها مياه
وبالتالي الحياه صعبه للغايه هناك ورغم كل
ذلك يقصف الجيش الاسرائيلي هذه المناطق
وهناك عدد من الشهداء والجرحى نقلوا الى
مستشفى ابو يوسف النجار
واصابات التي وصلت من هذا المنزل المستهدف
هي اصابات وصفت جراحها بانها خطيره للغايه
من جراء الاستهداف المباشر لهذا المنزل من
قبل الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه ايضا
القصف مكثف في مدينه خانيونس لا سما
المناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه لخان يونس منطقه
جورت لوت منطقه
الط واضا منطقه حي المناره وكذلك منطقه
وسط البلد تتعرض الى قصف عنيف الدبابات
الاسرائيليه تتواجد على اطراف هذه المناطق
وتقصد بعنف كل المناطق المحيطه بهذه
المنطقه وبالتالي القصف كان عنيفا على
خانيونس ونقل ايضا عدد من الاصابات كذلك
وتم انتشال عدد من الشهداء من عبسان وهي
من المناطق الشرقيه والتي كان من الممنوع
الوصول اليها من قبل طواقم الاسعاف وطواقم
الدفاع المدني لكن خلال اليومين الماضيين
طواقم مصره على الوصول الى تلك المناطق
وبالتالي انتشال عداد كبيره من الجثامين
والشهداء شكرا لك هشام زقوت مراس جزيره
كنت معنا من رفح